[Music]
all right as I mentioned earlier in my
opening monologue as we continue from
London tonight the media cannot stand it
that President Trump actually stood up
for America today on the world stage
just to remind you let's take a quick
look this is and I don't want to make
light of this but this kind of diplomacy
looks like Hulk smash all Germany a
captive of Russia is the most
inflammatory language I can imagine it's
the latest example of how the Trump
doctrine includes driving a wedge in the
world order by appending democratic-led
institutions in place since after World
War two I think he went there determined
to poke his allies and to demand not
only more spending but to insult Germany
what's going on here is there any
possible reason to believe this is good
for the world I told a stout here in
London with reaction former White House
chief strategist Stephen how are you my
friend good i see you thanks for having
me here um live in london live what is
it 2:00 2:30 in the morning for Millar
that's something like that let's go
today was historic yes it was the right
thing to do
pitch perfect and I don't think anybody
ever laid out those numbers and John
look at the meltdown on the mainstream
media in the permanent political class
of both parties the never Trump or
national security apparatus right and
also the left you know they have said
for years how disruptive Trump is here's
what he did think about the speech he
made in Warsaw last August
he said our number one priority is
defense of Western civilization and he
actually talked at that time about what
a problem Russian natural gas was gonna
be I mean for any other president been
so provocative he goes the NATO today
and he has a partner's discussion to say
look this alliance I'm trying to make it
stronger I want to I want allies I don't
want to protect it the problem is is
what NATO is turned into is a
protectorate you can see in those
numbers when in violet Donna she it's
not just for the American people should
understand it's not just that Germany's
only paying 1.2 percent of their GDP
when they have when they're positive in
their you know their positive in their
budget they got plenty of cash it's only
one point two percent but if you look at
where they're spending it on it's not on
equipment it's not on readiness it's not
on interoperability for NATO there's a
report out the other day the 128th I
think
German combat aircraft only seven only
seven are prepared to be fully
operational right now what President
Trump said today is that hey the key the
Trump doctrine no more manage decline
the elites in the world manage process
to unacceptable outcomes to citizens and
he's saying hey we're not doing that
anymore I'm going to have a partner's
discussion you need to pay the two
percent in fact he said instead of
waiting for two 2024 if you look at what
the threats are today you need to step
up and pay today by the way if you don't
pay it you should be in arrears and they
and all the guys who said I'd go with
that Trump is not engaged Trump's an
isolationist this is the most this is
what are you talk about this is total
engagement and in treating people like
adults everybody comes over in NATO
before our to Europe and they have all
this - talk but they only like apology
tour Steve they like a weak America it's
like billions sent over even people on
the on the Republican side of come over
here and just had platitudes Trump is a
pract
practical pragmatic businessman and he's
saying if we're to make this alliance
work people have to step up OK and
participate fully participate as far as
a 2% go and it can't be 10 years has got
to be today I think and this one of the
things that Trump drove president Trump
remember did thirty billion dollar
increase when we first got there just
for readiness and today after these
things in the morning they had the
readiness briefings I believe President
Trump came and said hey I think the
other thing about 4% he is into the
details of what it takes to make this
alliance work but you look on to the
mainstream media innocent full meltdown
this the first time anybody's had a
partner's discussion Poland is doing the
opposite of Germany they refuse to be
dependent on Russian energy sources you
when you talk about Germany literally if
Putin's a hostile regime Russia is a
hostile regime or Putin a hostile after
and you're gonna put 70 percent of the
light bloodier economy in his hands and
give them billions of dollars at NATO in
part is designed to protect against any
hostile regime like Russia it just
defies all common sense and logic
especially knowing the depth of American
resources with energy that's what he
said today he said how can you be so
relax and supporting NATO the defense
alliance and what we're here today is
talk about that when you're putting
really the control of your entire
country because if you fully do this
natural gas you'll be at 70% and look
back what is a 2009 2009 when when when
Russia put the pressure on Ukraine about
natural gas people have seen before
Russia do like I said he talked about it
in Warsaw last year he brought up today
today and nobody has really gotten in
the Russians faces like this I mean he
called out Germany but he also called
out Russia so I don't know what we're
seeing today how nervous you did not
like what you heard he's basically
saying don't do this I think I killed
the Russian economy I think if you're
Putin is sitting there going hey this
guy is the leader of the West he's
laying out very methodically what it
takes for the defense of the West that
they have to have an alliance that works
they have to have an alliance works
militarily they can't be any more games
you know if President Trump's got a
great saying no more games and today
said no more games he's ready we're
gonna pay for it and by the way you
can't if you're beholding to Russia
you're strategically going to put the
entire alliance in jeopardy okay let me
let me switch to the 2018 election I
make the point that the Democrat is no
vision to make to look out for the
working man or we said the Forgotten men
and women of this country this is their
agenda they want to impeach Trump but
they tell them Maxine Waters and others
don't say it they want to open borders
they want to keep Obama care they don't
want judge Cavanaugh on the on the bench
and they want their crumbs back they
want the tax cut back I can't think of
one positive thing they're offering but
historically midterms are difficult for
the party in power in the White House
it's difficult and party in power but
this is gonna be a referendum on
President Trump I keep saying this is
his first reelect and it should be
they're running away from saying
impeachment now because they understand
if Pietschmann galvanizes the deplorable
x' it galvanizes the base president
Trump is going to be an imbalance all
deplorable absolutely wears a badge of
an irredeemable deplorable wears a badge
of honor that's September 9th is a High
Holy Day in our movement because no you
saw you saw in that clip horrible what
she really thinks of working people they
detest you they detest your values that
if that's what you stand for and that's
what Trump speaks to the American people
Trump this is his reelect okay you're
going to get an up-or-down vote now that
you ain't get the whole package what
he's done on national Republicans what
about rhinos you gonna suck it up well
it's just like 2016 when President Trump
said talked about the judges right if
you if you're a establishment Republican
okay and you see what President Trump
represents with tax cuts where the
economy's going right with national
security all the leadership be shown and
he is
Riis reforming the federal judiciary
it's one of the reasons they're having a
meltdown right now because the left
understands that Donald Trump is his
historic president and he's going to be
in their lives for 30 or 40 years
by the way transformation transformation
but in one of the true historic
presidents maybe four or five in
American history he's going to be in the
lives of the progressive left for 30 or
40 years way he's redoing the federal
judiciary in a very methodical process
right to go to people who have a lot of
written opinions to go to originalist
for the constitution it's gonna have
dramatic impact I think that's why
you've seen the milk technology where
cabin also we're toast I think I think
kata Cavanaugh is a tremendous pick
trust the process I think he's a
tremendous Peck it's great to see and
long right good to see him